a bitter dispute that escalated into a
skirmish between protesters and police
in Memphis Tennessee these dramatic
scenes were filmed just recently when
demonstrators tried to cover the statue
of Nathan Bedford Forrest a former slave
trader Confederate General and suspected
leader of the Ku Klux Klan Tami Sawyer
organized the protest with the support
of Danielle Inez a young leader of the
Democratic Party in Memphis they both
find the side of general Forrest still
staring down at them unbearable
this structure of Nathan Bedford Forrest
needs to be removed because it
represents a hateful ideal that black
people are not an equal to white
Americans and knowing the beliefs of
Nathan Bedford Forrest it should not
stand in a city that is majority
african-american Memphis City Council
which is dominated by the Democratic
Party voted to remove the statue two
years ago but the Tennessee State
Legislative in Nashville disagreed the
Republican majority they are passed a
law that placed hurdles in the way of
anyone wanting to get rid of Confederate
monuments so we have to get a two-thirds
majority vote from a special committee
that's in place in Nashville but in
order to get a hearing we have to make
sure we notify every single person who
might have a vested interest in that
statue and if we go to the state and say
hey these are the people we've notified
if they come back and say oh you missed
one we have to start back over from
square one it's complicated this is in
fact not only a memorial to general
Forrest it's also his grave Nathan
Forrest and his wife are buried right
here under the statue which makes it
even more difficult to simply remove it
but besides his particularity there are
many here in the United States who are
opposed to the removal of such monuments
to the Confederacy on principle one of
them is President Trump who recently
tweeted it's sad to see the history and
culture of our country ripped apart and
according to the latest polls
a majority of Americans actually agree
with him
like mark Buchanan he is a member of an
organization called sons of confirmed
veterans the group is dedicated to
preserving Civil War sites such as this
former military outpost and to honoring
the memory of those who fought for the
south I can understand that people are
offended by these statues but it's
important to remember that it's much
more complicated than that
these men came back home after the war
and helped rebuild the country for
Buchanan monuments to Confederate heroes
are part of America's heritage and not
racist statements still the debate has
the potential to open old wounds and
race relations in Memphis of all places
where Civil Rights icon Martin Luther
King was murdered in 1968 I think they
should take you down things like that
are not really indicative of what our
country represents today so they should
take it down and put it maybe in a
museum where history belongs our history
is what you know this country is based
on you know how it's began and you know
it's I don't think someone should
terrorize or tear down or destroy things
that are part of you know what we stand
for
meanwhile Jamie Sawyer and her fellow
activists are already planning new
protests and they are optimistic that in
the end they will prevail we know we're
approaching the 50th anniversary of the
assassination of Martin Luther King jr.
and I believe that the city in the state
has too much invested in the recognition
and celebration of that for these
structures to continue to stand the
optics they are just you know not good
and so I believe that we're on the right
side of history with that there is
clearly no consensus here in Memphis or
elsewhere in the United States on what
to do about those monuments to the
Confederacy what does heritage what is
provocation and where do you draw the
line this debate is bound to continue
all over the country for many years to
come